welcome to this video playing I am
Providence John Bryant yeah played him
before and lost i don't remember what
this was okay a king's indian trying to
play play a classical variation this
ninety two lines is something that I
wanted to study there is a new one
opening DVD out by the Romanian
theoretician Mahama reen Michael Maron
as as yes as heroin tends to pronounce
it and he's advocating this this move
okay 97 this is a very M straightforward
way to play before it's a sort uncommon
mix of systems a 5 I don't know I don't
know the theory anyways Oh normally
normally what what black is doing with
not descent is playing in a very
straightforward fashion with f5 and he
doesn't do any moves on the queenside
but here he he decided to to play a 5
which looks like a mixture here of the
bionet and some other systems okay with
me going to be ored see what happens
Teague's should be forced the way to go
yeah I'm good k is to take with the rook
and now a form
yeah that very much looks like something
that could could arise from the bionet
attack so if I've I guess so is there
reason not to no one gets not take some
Luke cheeks this is pretty awful like I
think I know but what is he playing here
night c 5 maybe 0 he goes for that I
thought that this is pretty ugly but
maybe I don't really know don't really
know this line I thought rook takes
would be quite nice maybe I'm wrong rook
takes Bishop takes our games going for
that so is there a seagoing for
something like some c6 kind of setup
that that might be possible like that
group b 5 c6 no that's not even playable
and not be 566 however is playable
hmm okay I go Bishop e3 is still my
cheap on okay that wasn't really planned
but anyway I have to make a move at some
point okay okay so I'm taking d 7 & a 6
ok would be one nice looking quite
normal it's quite funny it's never doing
anything on the case is just playing on
the queenside all the time it shouldn't
be bad for white really looks like a
nice position I'm threatening Bishop d6
now already okay go into a 5 is for
Bishop d6 and c5
and we should be success as a threat
okay did not really react to that is
there is there something great for him
after Bishop d6 I don't know c5 comes
into consideration as well that this
looks nice right I don't see any tactic
and I'm threatening Bishop e7 and and
everything at the same time and takes
Queen takes ultimately the d6 pawn is
very weak and I'm a pawn up already
so some tactical III politics no no
tactic let's see
something like yeah III this something
like that is the only chance otherwise
black is just totally busted he might be
totally busted he anyway but it is still
a tricky business as usual okay if I
take bishop jakes yeah but I can't do
that let's just take and ask him what
what the precise compensation is night
f1 bishop age six right looks very
passive actually it looks very passive
but ok let live let's show me I'm going
to play G for next and take t6 okay he
wants to to enter on edge for yes I can
do it and I'm just saying that with the
two pawns I should be winning
well it should it should win but still i
know that i tend to screw up those kind
of things so how do i get the pawns in
motion look to be six then c5 c6 d6
probably I will play the bishop to you
five I guess
tending nights you form ok he knows that
I mean ok I don't think you had anything
great anyway but my head I don't really
see any any big counter play him just
too quick with the pawns
now I don't see anything the ship's e7
b7 and he's falling apart
what does somewhat weird way to play the
opening Bishop you 1f towards I'm
morning ok for v8
yeah I don't know the line at all but it
seemed very good for wide but I'm not
not an expert so my judgment there might
be might be a one sided or M precise ok
the check and he's got bishop efore
check but then i go to h3 so i'm going
to promote but I can play king after
whatever I want yeah come on let's do
that check check black resigns yeah it's
it just promotes yeah I don't really
know the opening but it it is it is I
don't know it is uncommon I think to mix
this this ideas 97 before it's
completely normal of course and then
then they normally play at five we have
this is this was played by by oh I don't
know the camera play 97 or 98 I mean
this is this is all very well known this
kind of thing this is how they normally
play this this opening something like
that if I was certainly uncommon it sort
of looks a little bit like a mixture of
systems what of course there is the
bionet attack and there a five is a
completely normal move takes sometimes
book takes and then a four and sometimes
the night comes over maybe we are
transposing to something like that I
don't know but it felt that around here
I'm I'm in pretty decent shape on the
queenside it's it's it's going I mean
I'm advancing their rather quickly okay
but it could be a transposition right
looks looks very much like a
transposition I think rook e8 is
sometimes an idea in those positions
okay went f5 I just went a f5 and now
night c5 is what the computer gives I
don't
no I mean roop cakes we ate yeah rupee
five looks a bit awkward but I didn't I
originally wanted to do this but he has
c6 yeah and this is very awkward good no
God no decent reply to that and this is
this is entirely strange I mean exposing
the rook like that so would be five yeah
a home and now yeah Bishop a success
maybe he has to do that I don't know
this looks nice for idea I mean I'm
opening i have opened up the a and B
file while blacks counterplay is still
kind of yeah not there yeah Bishop h6 is
the computer suggestion with about equal
plane it's not an easy move to make in
any case and now it gives starts to give
wider net jam Knight f3 I would
definitely would have played that Queen
d7 looks very messy so just go back here
I mean there's two pieces hanging I
difficult it's a difficult move to play
Bishop h6 after Bishop see a droopy one
olo white is winning already a computer
is on plus two so win-win already a
queen a to this is better than Queen a
fiver not really and now okay the
computer actually okay it says Knight d2
e4s even stronger because he cannot
prevent all the threats this is this is
this might as well be true yeah but I
wanted to get this in and it is also
winning up our route b6 comes into
consideration as well I a but this this
is interesting here here night d takes
e4 is a lot stronger actually you know
he has to know where he has no move this
is really a big issue I mean I'm taking
on b6 next move with the Queen and then
I get the same issue without this
three counterplay being possible this is
a plus three position really terrible ok
but I wanted to check is free and now
it's kind of continuing I'm struggling a
bit yeah it's still +1 something
according to the engine I get g4 in and
and it did it is it is a win but the
other things the other way of playing
was probably a little bit bill mid more
plain ok I like this I think it was a
pretty decent game thanks for watching